so this is really awesome we're just
establish how useful these things are
just just to get at like a really we
kind of home that you've already counted
we want to be able to work with these a
little better so we need some language
to to go with this okay so what I want
you to notice to give you some language
is that we can over here have a look at
these two solutions we can just like we
append like add on to the end any
rational number with a rational number
and we say well these guys can't mix
right you don't take oh what's what's a
simplified form of 3 plus root 5 3 plus
root 5 is the simplified form a rational
sorry rationals and Irrational's they
don't mix together they're kinda like
oil and water
right but they're they're in the same
number in the same way just like
rationals internationals let's just sort
of stick to their own bit in the same
number real and imaginary they so stick
they were a bit even the same number
okay in fact we call this bit the real
component of alpha and we call this bit
the imaginary component of alpha ok and
in correspondingly this is the real part
of beta and the imaginary part right
that's worth 20 actresses are convention
that what I'm talking about is the real
part is this number over here negative 1
and what I'm talking about as the
imaginary part is negative root 3 not
already over 3i negative root 3 that's
how much the imaginary stuff I have okay
because bi is the imaginary unit right
ok so if for instance I might not like
this particular complex pair of numbers
right when you put together real and
imaginary you get a complex number if I
were to write a general complex number
right it's going to have by the way I
forgot to mention this before I've been
riding it since
okay yeah right no I haven't ruined say
something right before the ready exit
I'm gonna start writing Zen's Zed's are
a way to indicate I'm interested in
complex numbers as well as real numbers
you also see I put a dash through mine's
ends you don't have to do that but in my
experience particularly when you're
reading it in if you're in a hurry and
you write as in and then right next step
you want to most people cannot tell
that's a Zed and it's who they look like
to twos or to Zed's so I right - mister
my says a general complex of about Syd I
can write that with a real part of the
glass and an imaginary part right B Y so
what I've got here is that the real part
of Z is a and the imaginary part of Z is
B okay
now if B was 0 B was 0
this would be a plus 0 - no imaginary
bit so I would call that number purely
real because there are no imaginary bits
to speak off right and in exactly the
same way if a was 0 right well all
you're left with is that B I so I call
that number purely imaginary but
together I call it complex ok this is a
complex number
alright one last thing I want to say
before I leave is before you remember we
said our complex conjugates these are
kind of useful as you can see they're
very handy so because of that we
introduce a notation to talk about them
if you've got some complex number Z and
you can write its complex conjugate as Z
bar like that's that's a little
different way I read this Z bar equals a
not plus bi but minus bi ok these comics
Wendy's it's a super useful
we'll come back to them again in the
future
okay now I want you to rely another bit
and I talked to you at the beginning
saying you cut legs numbers they kind of
like us trying to understand what the
universe is made of like Athens and
perch ones and quads etcetera yeah I
want you to imagine yourself as a
scientist at the Large Hadron Collider
and you just discovered a new kind of
particle you're like oh these buzz on
it's real we proved it as a scientist
what's the first thing you do once you
discover a new kind of object you don't
just say oh cool we found it it exists
now in that let's just shut the thing
down I know it's taking decades to build
billions of dollars but we've done our
job we're finished you don't do that you
want to understand this object right
you've discovered it that's just the
beginning you wonder how it works how it
behaves for the heeds but you know
what's its charge spin mass all that
kind of thing right the mess doesn't
relate because it gives everything vast
it's the same thing for complex numbers
we have just discovered a new object I
want to know how that works wonder how
behaves I want to know how to work with
it right now the mathematics we give
that process that then sort of scheme of
understand how these things relate to
each other we give that a name we call
it arithmetic right now complex
arithmetic is what we're going to look
at next lesson but before I am show that
before we get to that next lesson I want
to justify for you you know put over
here why is it worth spending actual
time just on a writ visit you maybe
that's a bit pedestrian isn't it like
plus minus times like what's the big
deal okay well let me justify for you
why arithmetic is so important if you
come back to when we were going through
all of the different all the different
kinds of numbers right I think I said
natural and then integers and rational
and then erection you recall first time
you learnt fractions right the first
time you learnt about rational numbers
some of the rules that you've thought of
before that were just obvious they don't
quite work the way you expected right so
for example two plus three we know is
equal to five no big deal
but one over two plus one over three is
not one plus one on two plus three right
it is not addition doesn't work like
that there's more nuances right you'd
have to get common denominators that
kinda thing and then off you go
and in the same way root 2 plus root 3
that's definitely not root 5 right this
again shows that the rules you've
established before you can't careful
with them when you go further down into
into the murky depths of what numbers
are really made of ok now let me show
you an example of that with complex
numbers so in complex arithmetic why do
you have to be so careful would you come
back to this line here
just this like do you remember I split
this number into a product and then just
casually I said yeah we can see that
this one third into two serves but not
have you batted an eye on it right
everyone said yeah that's cool I can
roll with that seems correct okay so
does that mean like how would you state
this by the way you've got the square
root on a product I would state that as
the square root of 8 times the square
root of B all right well now that we
know that complex numbers work usually
we would say up all of these guys have
to be positive right they're all only
allowed to be positive but now we're
like oh actually they don't have to be
positive they work just fine when
they're not so what will happen
when a and B are both negative one think
about this Ruby okay tell you left hands
I'm just honest but the left hand side
the square root of a B is negative one
times negative one well I just stuff on
the inside and I just go out with right
so negative one times thinking one is
just one squared of 1 is just 1 no big
deal right
what at the right hand side what's
happening on the right hand side I've
got the square root of a times the
square root of B and if there's one
thing a square root should do its when
you multiply it by itself
it had better give you back the number
that you started with right
or maybe not
well what's going on right and this is
pretty simple written into that it's
just you know some multiplying that kind
of thing but clearly as you can see just
like up here the rules that you've grown
to become familiar with like this record
is like an axiom okay it's axiomatically
true actually aren't always true okay
now why is it a true why doesn't it work
does that mean we couldn't do it here
does that mean I can't do it with normal
serves just calm down okay I will show
you why this is happening it's actually
really cool it will help you understand
what's going on here and show you that
you need to be careful but point is just
to justify complex routine right not to
restage that it's gonna be hard but
it'll be worth that once we understand
the way these things work eventually if
we come just as normal as having a half
and a third and that's what we're going
to look at next lesson